the measure of success of the web
service how many people are the very
last session after four very full day so
it's my pleasure to introduce Matt
Valerio from McMaster University will
tell us about tasting assignments to
constraint satisfaction problems thanks
okay first let me thank the organizers
has been a wonderful conference just
really interesting talk so so thanks
before I strongly acknowledge two
co-authors he be chen and yuuichi
yoshida I take great comfort and having
Hubie here because if there's any hard
questions asks I'm going to rely on him
to answer them so where is he hey
attention all right so this is a talk on
constraint satisfaction problem and as
all thoughts must start with we oops out
of the definition we've seen different
ways to present a class of problems and
here's one way we start with the
relational structure a fire relational
structure has a fine set at a finite
sequence of dietary relations and we'll
call a template sometimes and what's an
instance of the constraint satisfaction
problem over this template or the
structure it so it's a pair consisting
of a set of varieties Bryce variables
variables along with a bunch of
constraints and constraint consists of a
sequence of variables along with an
attached relation from our our structure
so we want to know whether there's a
solution to this particular instance it
was a solution it's an assignment of
values from our domain from the set a to
the variables V so that each of the
constraints is satisfied that is for
each constraint we have in our instance
the we sign our a look at the tuple we
get from this assignment it lives in
that that was the corresponding relation
okay okay which this girls will be
presented as an instance could be a
conjunction of
Tomic statements and we want to know
whether there's a satisfying assignment
to it right so and again every talk like
this must talk about graph k color
ability because this is a very nice
example of this we look at the structure
consisting of the numbers one through k
and the inequality relation on this this
set in an instance of graph k color
ability as you know just a graph and the
question fine a graph and the question
is can we assign colors to the vertices
so that no neighboring vertices will
have the same color and that amounts to
just a really an instance of the there's
a corresponding instance of the CH BR of
the structure and the grass is kate
colorable if only if this instance has a
solution can we assign values 1 through
k to the vertices so that pairwise we
never get the same color for edge
related vertices all right so standard
example and yes as we all know when K is
to this is a decision problem is in P
and otherwise it's an np-complete
problem
and well have to also mention the the
classic decision problem here given a
template and an instance of the CSP are
this template we want to know whether it
has a solution ah yes yes or no this
this is an MP prob complete problem in
general but for certain templates we
actually get this problem lying in the
class p the federal rd conjecture just
states that really there only two
possibilities for a given template
others problem is easy or it's as hard
as it can be I'm not going to talk about
this conjecture today I want to talk
about a different sort of problem in
libris talk he he he talked mostly about
the decision problem but talked about
other sort of directions one could go
with with with this and this is one yet
another application of the ideas that
leave our talked about and it has to do
with property testing so here here's the
setup we've got a template a and we've
got an instance of CSP or this template
and I want to know whether a given
function an assignment is a solution or
not how hard is that to decide well it's
not so hard right this this problem this
problem class is an NP so there is a
fast way to certify that a given
function is a solution right and in fact
depending on the computational model you
could even argue it's a linear time
problem so here I'm assuming that have
random access to this function or some
Oracle has the function at hand and I
can query the Oracle checking various
values and in sort of linear time the
number of constraints I can get a
decision out whether this is indeed a
solution or not ok it's not so important
is just there's a fast way to check
whether something is a solution or not
but fast as fast and maybe this this
number of variables is extremely large
like billions and billions and it'd be a
real drag to actually to check every
single variable to see whether we have a
solution on so even though it's a
quickly testable kind of thing it could
take up a lot of resources to actually
decide this and maybe one make these
decisions so quickly on the fly with
using few resources so if we relax our
requirements who have sort of absolute
certainty whether of the given
function in hand is a solution or not we
can test it and said so here's what i
mean by testing an assignment i'll
elaborate this on this in a second but
if i don't want to know for sure whether
i have in hand a solution or not what if
I just say want to test quickly
distinguish between satisfying
assignments versus assignments they're
really rather far away from any
satisfying assignment so that's that's
what we're going to be considering how
can we come up with testing algorithms
to to deal with this sort of address
this sort of question and under what
circumstances will such a nice testing
algorithm exists now in general really
the best we could do would be
essentially to read every single value
here and then check whether it's a
deciding a silent or a satisfying
assignment in this way but for some
certain special templates we can quickly
test whether something's far from an
assignment or is an assignment as we'll
see so are you willing to use randomness
yes right yes we're gonna relax we don't
have will be certain what this thing
will be a probabilistic sort of
algorithm that with high probability
will be able to distinguish between a
function that is satisfying versus far
from set being satisfying so yeah so I
use the word far a few times I need to
talk about some sort of metric here and
and here's one will use so given a
template a and an instance of of CSP
over a I want to also come have a weight
function attached to the variables
essentially probability distribution on
it and I went back and forth on whether
i should include this or not we could
have just dealt with this sort of
uniform weighting system here but we're
going to allow this waiting arbitrate
waiting system on function on on our set
of variables so given two assignments
from functions v2a the distance between
them according this weighting function
is just the weights of the variables
with
these two functions difference kind like
a Hamming distance if this were the
uniform weight function and that's
pretty much we're talking about here so
a dis a measure between we can apply to
two different functions from V to a so
now we introduce another parameter
epsilon it's kind of our error tolerance
here a number between 0 and 1 and we'll
say that F is epsilon far from
satisfying the instance I if it's rather
far away from any satisfying assignment
so there's no it's not close in this
sense to any satisfying assignment ok so
again going back to our testing we want
to be able to determine with
distinguished with high probability
functions that are satisfying versus
those that are rather far away from from
any satisfying assignment well so yeah
so now we have to dusar what it will
mean by a tester is a probabilistic
algorithm so again given the template a
relational structure a tester for CSP a
is an algorithm falling features so on
input what we're going to give it this
this epsilon R error tolerance an
instance of CSP of a and again we might
as well assume it's outside ball or else
really there's nothing to test here but
let's not worry about that we have this
weight function attached to the instance
and again there's this hidden this
unknown assignments we have query access
to a system Oracle that has this this
assignment and we get to make queries of
it again we don't get to see the whole
thing otherwise we could just see
ourselves whether it's a solution or not
and the output is either yes or no if
this assignment is a satisfying
assignment then our algorithm with high
probability will output yes now high
here is is two-thirds this is just some
more less arbitrary number we it's used
in these instances we can amplify this
make this a bigger number if you want a
lot more certainty just by running this
tester several times but anyway so we
want
put to be yes if we do and have in hand
a satisfying assignment again yes with
high probability and no whenever the the
function is rather far from any
satisfying assignment yes all of this
weight on the four million you know you
wouldn't find that unless it was yeah so
let's see if I know the answer to that
question how is the weight function
visually to know yeah we do have the
weight function sitting in promise so
it's just the the against this this
function here that we don't have access
to right so this is all given to us the
instance and a weight function for the
variables and and we have query access
to the this function a function is as
big as the assignment right yeah it's as
big as the instance to right right yeah
you sample according to the week ocean
yes we're going to point to that yet so
do you need to have a description of it
if you can sample from it is booked okay
these are questions I'm not sure I can
answer so it's
we're gonna be sampling according to
this weight function so I'm not sure
that's standard just built into the
Oracle calls where you just make a call
the Oracle and the Vulcan that's that's
table that question on ya little
distributions that's right
okay so that's where after we want to
know what we want to devise testers for
for constraint satisfaction problems
over some fixed template a and for the
most part that the testers will be
looking at are called one-sided we this
this does allow for us to miss certain
functions that actually are satisfying
assignments but the ones we deal with
are called one-sided that they're always
correct for this so if it is a
satisfying assignment then it will
always give us the s value out yeah so
as you can tell perhaps this is a
concept that's i'm not expert in my
contribution here is to sort of describe
the templates which we do have nice
testers so i think i understand this
concept well enough to at least be able
to present a simple instance of what I
mean was meant by a tester so suppose I
have the property one to test is whether
a string of bits is constant zero ok so
imagine having a billion bits there and
you want to know whether it's constant
zero you could check them all but that
could take a long time suppose I just
want to check the property is yes so
suppose my epsilon is is 0.1 and I want
to sort of figure out with some high
probability whether this this this bit
sequence has more than ten percent of
one so saves a billion say a million
million bits here and I want to know
whether there's more than a hundred
thousand ones in there not well what's
the test could be just a randomly sample
I think 30 would do it 30 random bits
and if I don't see a one then i will i
will accept yet say yes otherwise i'll
say no and you can do the calculation
that independent of this 1 million or 1
billion sampling 30 bits randomly will
with high probability will see a 1 if
more than ten percent of the bits are
are one so that's the kind of tester
we're talking about here
good so let's see
right so time time could be an issue
when you're doing these sorts of testing
but the resource that we really want to
control is the number of queries we have
to make it could be that it's very
expensive to query the Oracle to get to
get values out maybe the function stored
some way a long long way away or maybe
it's expensive to transmit the this
information maybe don't want to transit
the whole solution because the lines are
unsecured so you want to minimize the
number of values to actually have to
check for various reasons so this leads
the notion of a query complexity of the
tester and will say the query complex of
a tester is constant if for fixed f
epsilon no matter how many variables are
dealing with we only need to make a
constant number of queries to get our
answer out and we could relax I to have
a sub linear complexity where as a
function of the number of variables in
our instance the the number of queries
make is is a sub linear function and and
of course the worst case just going to
be making a linear number of queries
linear in the number of variables of
course when we make epsilon smaller and
smaller will expect the number of
queries to grow but for a fixed epsilon
independent on the number of variables
we want to know whether we can get away
with a constant number of queries or not
as will call the queer complexity of CSP
of a to be constant sub linear linear if
if as a tester with that particular
query complexity yeah again in the worst
case it's always going to be linear
right because if you see the whole thing
then you can get your answer them so
here's the problem given a template
given a finite relational structure how
do you determine the query complexity of
the constraint satisfaction problem over
that template and here's some background
some known results for two coloring yes
has constant query complexity the disk
or like this this example I just gave
that if you have a big graph you just
need to sample a small number of
vertices to see whether the function you
have in hand it really is a two-color
get with high probability or far away
from one here's some non constant query
complexity templates to sat it's
sublinear
and again it's not constant it has this
as a lower bound for the queria
complexity even some nice csps have bad
query complexity so these are all have
linear query complexity this this is a
tractable instance of the CSP but it's
nevertheless that's not going to help us
with with Corey complexity Yoshida and
bhattacharyya have solved this problem
over the two element template
essentially doing a fish lost track of
the name we do the two element the
bullying CSP Shepherd shepherd type
result for for this problem over 2
element templates and again they got
they got a sort of mirror this
trichotomy for for the over the tools
and templates
yeah and again in some sense of reason
I'm involvement is because this is
essentially an algebraic sort of problem
that that the the observation of Yoshida
is that that the query complexity of
cspa is determined by a particular
algebra this is the algebra
polymorphisms of the structure and this
is one that leave our talked about
yesterday so I won't go into this in too
much detail but a polymorphism we've
been calling these symmetries is a
function on the the domain of the
template that preserves each of the
relations in this sense another way to
see us as these are functions that are
homomorphisms from for some K a to the K
the structure into a again there's their
symmetries of the template so that we
got it together all these polymorphisms
we get an algebra an algebra as a set
with a bunch of operation so this is the
algebra of polymorphisms of the the
relational structure and yoshida
observes that that this this complexity
is totally determined by by the
properties of this algebra so the game
now is to uncover the the algebraic
properties that will say determine
whether this has constant query
complexity or not so a couple of
examples more or less going over the
list we will actually no sir examples of
polymorphisms that will come up and i
think lee board did mention some of
these in his talk of am also of
operation is a function that satisfies
these two equations you've all seen
algebras with this kind of operation in
phrygia group the operation x times y
inverse times z satisfies these
equations that's a months of operation
any algebra with an additive structure
will have one of these things a majority
operation is another ternary operation
that satisfies well these majority
equations an example of such a analogy
with such a structure operation as a
lattice the operation X meet Y join X me
Zed join y meet Z is majority
check that and a generalization of this
too we call a near unanimity operation
it's this is a 3 airy near unanimity
operation this is a general version
these things sort of occur in nature but
there may be a little artificial mean
they do come up and they're important to
what I would have to say ice will come
back to these will see these little
later on so 10 places that have or don't
have these sorts of things the template
for graph to coloring has both Maltsev
and majority polymorphisms in fact any
structure whose relations are graphs of
by actions will have both of these
things so there there have a very rich
set of symmetries three land p again we
saw this yesterday are just the
structure or the p element field who's
that have binary and ternary relations
that are essentially a fine over the
over the space and because it supports
an avid structure will have a Malta
polymorphism but you can check that has
no majority polymorphism and the
structure that codes up to sat will have
majority about no motive so there's
various combinations possible here and
again we'll see these a little later on
when we State our theorem and finally
again leave I mentioned this that the
structure for / 3sat has only trivial
polymorphisms all right so here's a
result that yuuichi presented at Fox
last month it does sell this problem we
know exactly under what circumstances
the the CSP a day will have a constant
query tester and in fact it's exactly
what it has this this these two nite
symmetries a majority and am all set
polymorphism
yeah this maybe isn't so critical but
but these kinds of structures that have
both operations have been well studied
by algebraic universal algebra is these
are called arithmetic that the the
equation elyria of such algebras are
said to be arithmetic varieties and
example of such an algebra if you take a
funny product of finite fields then such
an algebra will have these two kinds of
operations so they will be arithmetic
and Pixley observe that in fact this one
symmetry this one polymorphism will give
rise to both of these and vice versa if
you have both of these you can get one
of these so just a more convenient way
to capture take this property here
having a Pixley turn good so what I want
to do is in the next last few minutes to
just talk about the the proof at some
level really want to illustrate how
having these kinds of symmetries will
allow us to devise a good tester of
course I don't have a whole lot of time
which is probably a good thing so let's
look at the negative side if a fails to
have one or both of these kinds of
symmetries these polymorphisms and why
will there not be a good tester well
this is where some interesting algebra
comes into the picture if an algebra has
a matzav operation but fails to have
majority then one can capture that in in
more structural ways it turns out that
that this will happen if and only if the
structure in some sense interprets a
module or some sort of additive
structure and in the way that Li worth
talking about yesterday so really if our
template fails to have both of these
polymorphisms then it can PP interpret
modules and since testability over the
quite complexity of testing over say an
additive structure like a module is
going to be linear that carries over to
the the template a so in the negative
side we find bad interpretable
structures and that lifts too bad query
complexity for the original the Givens
template there's another reason for
there to be have constant quarry
complexity and that is if we fail to
have a massive operation then we can
peep you interpret a structure that has
a single binary flexes but not symmetric
operation fair relation and again we can
use that that's going to have bad query
complexity and that lifts up to the
given template you modify an argument
from Fisher for to set to get this lower
bound for the query complexity of CSP a
in this case here so there's a quick
sketch of the situation when we don't
have both of these nice symmetries on
the other side we we're going to use
these these polymorphisms to to really
rewrite our instance it might take some
time but not so much both both for me
and and for the pre-processing you
imagine starting with some random
instance with the huge arity relations
and lots of variables what we can do is
pre process things to convert this into
a much better instance to deal with it
has the same set of solutions what we
get is an instance where all the
constraints are binary so every variable
we have this domain this algebraic
structure a sub X a sub y and all the
constraints between variables will be
binary and between any two variables
there will be a constraint so we have
this nice complete graph constraint and
equity network if you like and we use
the majority polymorphism to reduce high
arity constraints down to binary we also
stabbed with some sort of local
consistency so given any two-edged
related elements in these two domains
and given the third here there will be a
way to complete this in this way so we
can use a majority polymorphism to
really transfer the original problem in
too much nicer one
the way we use the malts that
polymorphism is as follows so given to
these these domains say over the
variable X and the variable Y what
follows from this multi polymorphism is
that the constraint relation R XY is
very much like a function that there are
compatible equals relations in both
domains such that r is essentially just
taking it's a function mapping classes
to classes so the x marks them gives us
really nice picture of what these
constraint relations are the majority
allows us to really reduce things down
to this this situation and well we have
to do a fair amount of more priests
osprey processing using these two
constraint relations in the end well we
get to the point where we can it becomes
more less transparent so the testing
amounts to sort of testing in the end so
we'll transform to the point where we
get lots of isomorphisms beteen between
domains and so the testing will be just
to select a bunch of points and seeing
whether they the the function f respects
these isomorphisms yeah i don't think
you can say a whole lot more given the
time let me just skip over the sequence
of reductions that allows us to
transform this into essentially a
transparent sort of instance yeah so I
did this in passing mention those things
but but in the end we get the following
kind of result that if our template has
these two nights polymorphisms then the
query complexity will be constant and on
the order of this so of course it's
epsilon gets smaller we'll need to
sample more points and it grows in this
way just to wrap up and the yeah it's a
one sided arrow tester as well we could
extend this to the situation where we
allow existential quantifiers this is a
richer class of problems to consider and
again the same paper we get a trichotomy
that again sort of looks like the result
we just I just dealt with if we have
both these nice polymorphisms the
there's a constant query tester for this
larger class of problem this larger
class of problems and otherwise it's not
constant we have this middle ground
where there's a sub linear
and that's when we have one of these
near unanimity polymorphisms and
otherwise we get to the linear case csba
so it's it's work where we allow some
it's a primitive positive formula so we
have some existential we have some free
variables and then some quantified
variables and then a conjunction
involving both the X's and Y's we want
to know yet so 5x is a PP formula and we
want to know we're testing whether an
assignment to the variables X is a
solution or not or far from one so yeah
we allow whereas in CSP we don't allow
quantifiers here it's just that's right
so this is a richer class of problems
and we're somehow our methods we have
been our interpretation we're using lots
of existential quantification so we just
we can get this out and the end of the
problem is can we get this trichotomy
just for their usual old CSP that's an
open question we have some interesting
ideas on that but just haven't panned
out yet so that's it today what happens
if you don't allow those sweets
yes straight with you with uniform well
I think we internally will need to deal
with them because one of the in our
reductions we have to split variables
into two and so we have to sort of split
the weight of that one variable into two
equal parts so I think internally have
to sort of track this these weights more
difficult so what don't you get more say
these easy cases I say so in it yeah so
we're some the class we just allow the
uniform weights is that how much so I'm
not sure that's the need a good way to
resolve this this thing at least in part
yep thank you question sorry yeah is
there a little ation ship between this
epsilon testing and probabilistic
probabilistically checkable proofs and
hardness approximations um I i have not
Hubie help me out here I'm not really so
yeah yeah I don't know anything about
that son torture is it oh please I asked
if there was a relationship between
epsilon testing and probabilistically
checkable pretty a lot of this framework
of testing was developed in order to
understand what was going on we they got
me like PCP but maybe like a high-level
you could say that in DC piece you want
to I mean the PCPs are formatted in some
nice way to allow for a small number of
queries but here we're not really
formatting you just have a plain
assignment right so that's maybe a high
level difference but in general that led
to the question you know when can we tap
what types of things
so here's an example of that right the
same people working on both problems
this is the main relationship not me no
I mean origin of get apps right well
thank you very much